[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns on here welcome to my 39th
episode of chest trap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profiled trap aligned
against Queen d3 veresov attack from the
Black respect to you the opening arises
after the following model d4 Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 so white is planning to
play d4 and grab space in the center and
accordingly black shouldn't allow this
and that's why defy is a fitting reply
okay here comes the trademark veresov
attack move Bishop to g5 and once again
the idea is very obvious what white
wants to do is he wants to capture this
knight give black a double pawn and then
at the right time play the movie foe and
get some good advantage in upcoming
decade
well once again black children allowed
this and accordingly Knight B to d7 is a
fitting reply
stopping all white threats now as I have
highlighted over here white has tried
various responses such as Knight to f3
III however by far the second most
popular choice by white is to play Queen
to D 3 which has a clear intention to
hit with E 4 and castle on the print
side now against this aggressive setup
I'm going to recommend a very tricky
move by the black namely c6 and the trap
II platform sets right here guys if you
open and continue with the movie 4
however if white plays other moves such
as Knight to f3
then you can go through the tail section
where either g6
or Queen to e5 both leads to equal play
by black let's see what is wrong with
this obvious choice evil which in fact
as for the database played in more than
170 games which I am afraid not a good
choice for the white camp the trapping
business start with the following model
d capture c4 Knight captures e4 Knight
captaincy for Queen captures e4 and now
here the old mu is queen - if I check
which to my surprise played in more than
90 games however modern engine and
theory suggests that after Queen to b6
white is having some huge problems in
this line believe it or not but the only
mo in this position is Bishop to c1
which I don't think so
any of your opponent will consider and
anyways if white has to take this Bishop
out first and then put it back then
black will obviously gain advantage in
the opening the more common approaches
either the move b3 or castle on the
Queen side and that's where the real fun
start let's see each by turn and find
out how quickly black get upper hand in
the opening the first more I want to
consider is castle on the Queen side
which is in fact played in ten games
however this is a big time mistake guys
as Black has this little reply yup Queen
- fi attacking - soft spot and suddenly
in a huge trouble well all the game in
the database continued with D Phi which
is in fact the only logical choice after
Queen captures a - blah
as one upon on just ninth move of the
game and no matter however white plays
this pawn loss hasn't been justified for
example the first move I want to
consider is D capture c6 which looks
very obvious and after the force reply
be capture c6 and Quinn capture c6 at
first sight this position looks too good
for the white but after just one look to
be aged and suddenly it is now black who
is in the driving seat nope white cannot
play the movie three the simple reason
is after Queen Jack came to d2 and Quint
way if I check white lost the piece just
within the opening stage so that's not
possible
and the only more in this position which
saves the b2 pawn is Queen to c3 but
after that the task is very easy first
Queen check and after King to b2 and the
move Queen captures be tuned at the end
of whole transaction not only why it has
a misplaced King but black emerged with
a clear pass porn on the a file and with
some careful play this is definitely a
huge advantage to the black camp
probably the most critical move in this
position is Bishop to c4 which develop a
piece as well as attacking the Queen but
still this is not enough as after Queen
check King to D - Queen - if I check it
doesn't matter whatever white plays for
example the best magician here is King
to e2 afterwards
remember this saving resource night to
b6 attacking to sport and now again
however white plays he get bad position
from the opening
there's a nasty trap here that if white
goes for this tactic namely decap to c6
so his idea is when black captured this
bishop then he wants to take on b7 so
that way he munch few ponds and force
black to capture with the bishop but in
fact after Queen captures b7 just one
move Queen to g4 check any turn out that
it is white who has miscalculated the
whole variation the second move I want
to consider is b3 which is in fact
played in more than 17 games and against
this black has this crafty move Knight
to f6 attacking the Queen the first
question comes into your mind is well
that simply allowed this bishop to
capture this night right well yup
white can do that except there's a huge
problem that after this Queen check
white is forced to move his scaling and
then we will take with the Jeep on so
that white King can completely caught at
the center of the board
so Bishop captures f6 is right out of
the equation again as for the database
majority of the games continue with
Queen to d3 where black has mostly
replied with g6 however I found out
another crafty move from this position
namely if our well White has various
choices as I highlighted over here but
if you check in engine it will says that
against each of this it is black who is
having a slight advantage however the
move which white shouldn't play and
looks very natural
d captures 'if i run into some nice
static first of all black has this check
and white has the only move namely c3
what happens if he continued it bishop
to d2 well this is a big mistake as
after Bishop captures d2 Queen captures
d2 and the Moon Knight to e4 we have a
double threat so white response is force
white has to play Queen to e3
but after that kwinto if I check create
some nasty problems to the white camp
well if he moves the King then again his
King will remain in the center so
accordingly the only good response here
is c3 trying to give the pawn back but
instead of capturing with the Queen
Black has a very nice reply Knight
capture c3 if white doesn't block it
then we can deliver the skull check with
Knight to be one so the only response
looks like Queen to d2 blocking the file
and pinning down the night but in fact
this is a big time mistake as after just
one move Bishop to g4 black has some
multiple devastating threats such as
rook to d8 as well as Queen captures
ePHI and no matter however white plays
his King will not survive longer
finally let's check what is happening
after the move C 3 and this is what I
like about this variation even though
there are two pieces hanging black has
this another dazzling move here
can you guessed it yup Knight to e4 what
a move this move creates multiple
threats
number one there is Queen captures f2
number two
that is Bishop capture see three number
three Knight captures GFI and even
though White has a choice of capturing
either of these two piece still he get
the losing position isn't that wonderful
well the first choice is very bad has
after Queen captures evil Bishop capture
c3 black just won the exchange at the
13th move of the game
okay what about pawn captures before
well more or less same story as after
Queen captures f2 check King to d1 and
now Knight captures defy again we have
the same story not only is this f1
Bishop is hanging but after Bishop to g4
and rook to d1 White King cannot survive
such a dangerous attack last but not
least here the best response for the
white is to play Bishop to e3 counter
attacking the black queen but has
happened in different variations it is
black who is coming on top of all this
technical variations the forcing line
start with Bishop capture c3 so if the
King moves then Queen to Aoife is a very
strong reply so a White Queen has to
take this bishop and after Knight
capture c3 Bishop captures b6 a captures
b6 at the end of the sequence there is a
pressure on a2 and the only way to
resolve this pressure is to play a four
but after that Bishop to e6 again Black
is munching the pawn just within doping
stage well the chess engine suggested
white should give up the pawn and play
the Mook into d2 however this is not
enough has after Knight to e4 check King
to e3
and now the star moon
Knight to c5 and by force black is
winning the pawn on a broad daylight and
andrewsl can shows that not only white
King is misplaced but the leading
development as well as extra pawn gives
black a huge advantage that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this wonderful
trap in the Queen d3 d4 variation
remember once you open and play the
movie foe
exchange on e4 and then rather than
playing the move Queen - if I play this
tricky move Queen to b6 and after this
when white plays some of the natural
responses such as b3 or castle on the
Queen side then disaster is awaiting for
him and with the strappy lines you can
get some great victories just within the
opening stage thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I will meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care